considera la fórmula wv / t donde p
representa potencia w representa trabajo
y sus unidades se miden en joe's que se
puede representar como kilogramo por
metro al cuadrado todo sobre segundo al
cuadrado y te representa tiempo y sus
unidades de medida son en segundos
ahora cuando tú tomes una clase de
física te vas a familiarizar con cosas
como jules que pueden ser presentadas
como kilogramos por metros cuadrados
todo sobre segundo al cuadrado y también
te vas a familiarizar con el término
potencia ajá pero aquí vamos a aprender
a manipular estas unidades para que
tengan sentido entonces bueno aquí dice
lo siguiente dice selecciona una unidad
de medida apropiada para la potencia si
tú recuerdas lo que hemos visto en
múltiples veces a nuestro tiempo
estudiando matemáticas es que en cierto
nivel puedes manipular las unidades en
la misma manera que puedes manipular
variables o números
entonces si potencia es equivalente a
trabajo entre tiempo también podríamos
decir que las unidades para potencia
serán igual a las unidades para trabajo
entre las unidades para tiempo entonces
las unidades para trabajo son los shows
podemos escribir el sobre y las unidades
para tiempo son los segundos entonces
tenemos luz sobre segundos pero no vemos
como respuesta a cierto es no no está
como una opción entonces lo que haremos
es poner a dos goles como kilogramo por
metros al cuadrado sobre segundos al
cuadrado así que hagamos eso entonces
esto será igual a jules que lo podemos
escribir como kilogramo por metro al
cuadrado
sobre segundos al cuadrado
y todo esto lo vamos a dividir entre
segundos y bueno eso que es igual
podríamos describir esto de la siguiente
manera esto será igual a kilogramos por
metros al cuadrado sobre segundos al
cuadrado ajá y dividimos esto entre
segundos entonces bueno lo que es lo
mismo multiplicaremos por 1 sobre
segundos baja 1 sobre s ahí está ahora
si manejamos a estas unidades de la
misma manera en la que manejamos a cosas
como variables esto será igual a en el
numerador tendríamos kilogramos por
metro al cuadrado sobre en el
denominador tenemos entonces segundos al
cuadrado por segundos tenemos entonces a
la s a la tercera potencia así que una
manera de expresar las unidades para la
potencia puede ser kilogramos por metros
al cuadrado sobre segundos al cubo
y aquí está esa opción así que lo
hicimos bien